I'm Beatriz.
I came all the way from
Brazil to talk to you
about how to make awesome
automations with GitHub
Actions.
So anyone here
has to run scripts
like every day, every
week, every month.
If you do that, GitHub Actions
probably will be useful to you.
So I'm here to talk about
what is GitHub Actions
and how can we run
R scripts with it.
So GitHub Actions
has been heavily used
by R packages
package developers
and for running checks on
packages, building the package
website and documentation.
And if you are a
package developer,
you can easily do
that using package
usethis, which is
my favorite package.
And you can also see a
lot of other examples
in this awesome r-lib
actions repository.
So how important is GitHub
Actions to RStudio and Posit?
So I look up in the GitHub
um, action API, GitHub API
to get the action run.
And we can see that in two
years the runs completed runs
for these, these
organizations, which
stores our favorite
packages, increase it
more than four times.
So GitHub Actions is really
important for RStudio and Posit
to run checks on R packages
and build the documentation
and stuff.
But I told you about what
package developers can do.
But most people that I know
are not package developers.
So I'm here to talk about guys,
how you can use that as well.
I've been using it two
years and in the beginning
it was a bit hard for me.
So I'm trying to facilitate
this process, right?
So we can run arbitrary
R scripts, like scrape
data from the internet.
I do that a lot, but the
government data. Run reports
with R Markdown, in Quarto.
We can send emails
and save results all
doing GitHub Actions with R.
So this is a simple
example of workflow file,
but I don't expect you to
understand this right now.
But the point is this first
part, we have the events
and this part tells when
the workflow should run.
In this case, we have
a button to press.
So when we press a button,
we start the workflow
and also we have a schedule.
So I'm telling the computer
that it has to be run every day.
The second part is the
name of the workflow,
and the third part is what
the workflow should do.
So this part of the jobs part.
Imagine that it's a virtual
machine that belongs to GitHub.
There is nothing
installed and you
have to tell what
it should, what
should be installed in
order to run our script
and what should be done.
So I'm telling that I want
to run a Ubuntu machine.
You can also use like Windows
machine and Apple machines,
macOS machines. And
I'm installing R,
but this is super easy because
of the r-lib action repository.
There is a setup there
that we just use it.
And then I'm saying that I
run I want to run my awesome R
script in the end.
And remember that part.
You have to install
all the packages there,
otherwise it won't
work, it will break.
So this is a really quick
presentation and I prepared
more examples in my
blog and I couldn't.
I hope I will
continue to do that.
So you can see more
examples there.
I would like to thank especially
RStudio for the diversity
scholarship.
Otherwise I couldn't be here.
R Ladies, Curso-R.
The creators and contributors
of our r-lib/actions
and Articulation.
And you can find me on Twitter
and my blog is Bea Milz dot com.
Thank you.